я закликав євреїв покинути Росію тому
що
відпускається залізна завіса не можна
казати що вони всього зомбовані Там
тоді я намагався разомбувати їх Україна
сьогодні з'явився історичний шанс
Всевишній дав
побудує державу там не знаю
найпроцвітаючу у світі победа це
це перемога саме перемога це не
Перемир'я
победа
[музика]
Україна Ми з тобою
ми спекуємо з головним рівним України з
мушерований Асман людены акав же багатий
уроки у духовним лідером єврейської
еспельноти в Україні та Люди на Яка за
Парші невинні у Найт і жебраки унай
найстрашніший годинник у лютому березні 2022
уроку не почула Україну Ми за розбили
центральну синагогію вас знаю, що там
дивує старших днів так само стало
щепленням для багатіїв людей Розкажи що
тут Що тут було у нас було
там у нас був центр біженців тут центр
біженців у нас був тобто спочатку через
того, що незрозуміло було звідки куди
тікати звідки тікати і що відбувається
то ми тут організували центр всього
гуманітарної допомоги роздачі роздавали
Наші волонтери
це підгузки дитячі кілька
піддонів там роздають ще різні їжу
ліки отримували гуманітарну допомогу
велику і стежив Я стежу До речі щоб по
дорозі не вкрали вибачте за вираз
тому що таке кажуть що таке
трапляється в Україні тому я намагаюся
стежити якщо те що ми отримуємо щоб
особисто контролювати щоб вона дійшла до
того кого потрібно Тут ми в синагогу
приходили тисячі біженців зараз люди
ось які приходять у Києві теж дуже
багато біженців ми допомагаємо і по Україні
в інших містах Ну так та всього на
екрані приходить ми роздаємо і дуже
приємно люди з радістю з радістю
[музика]
добре рано
Ну ось зараз ми роздаємо
тут я так розумію і так і
їжа та різні речі необхідні
[музика]
Це велика молитовна зала Тут було
кожен день під час війни тут по
кілька Сочі коли особливо коли ми
змогли вивозити з Чернігова та
чернігівську область А тоді було нас
коли обстріли були жарти і коли люди
по тижні
були під землею там були без їжі без Ось
це ще холодно було холодом без
опалення без
без нічого ми їх вивозили сюди.
люди були
Я хочу наголосити на цьому були всі українці
ні у нас був дуже багато більшість
було тут українців ми не дивилися на
тому національність ми його возили
всіх і тут Було ось по 300 чоловік ось
у цю синагогу прийняли люди приїжджали
сюди як у шоці були
людей, які пережили стільки страшне
таку страшну Трагедію ось ми тут
навіть я навіть сам уже не психолог
психологічну допомогу хтось подарував
наприклад ананас Я пам'ятаю багато на нас ось
це подарував якийсь я їм ми нарізали
нас я їм розносив вони були ось у нас у
нас ресторанний стравохід м'ясо людям це
було так вони посміхалися Але люди були у
шоковому стані виводив їх так жартами
такими я їм співав там тоді ось і ось
так його роблять із шокового стану у
їх було трохи забезпечуючи синагога на
побудована потужна така це була країна
1898 року
у дорозі дороги
намолене місце та й по-третє ми не
боїмося нікого крім Бога одного тобто
лютого відразу такий же ваш звірний недуже
Емутін з вірні не в цю дід
запасалим Росії до євреїв Росії просто
до російських людей
з одним посланням люди Зупиніть війну
і дивіться що вам говорять
телебаченню це брешуть вам
за раз уже більше не йшли в руку.
початку провини вища верета що росіяни
що Європі знаходиться в Росії може зуби
знайти провину
дивіться це був Крик душі це було Навіть
я не робив як не спеціально зроблено
постановочне відео Це був Крик душі та
цього дня саме обстріляли бабіяр
тоді ось потрапили ось коли потрапили три
ракети бабіяр я вже це було таке
емоційний
Крик душі назвемо але він як написано у
наших книгах слова вихідне серце
входить інше серце цей Крик увійшов на
насправді
десятки може сотні мільйонів людей
представляли це відео ось воно тобто
воно свого Facebook розійшлося на весь
світ в першу чергу було важливо для
росіян щоб у них розплющились очі
тому що вони сидять
дивляться цей телевізор який бреше 24
години на добу і потім з розумним виглядом ідуть
вбивати людей сюди і ось це страшно то
є я намагався їх зомбувати пояснити
ми повинні намагатися зробити навіть якщо
моя така, що завжди потрібно намагатися навіть
говорити лікар каже що хворий
[музика]
хворий смертельно хворий так
Всі ми повинні його лікувати чому ж
раптом лікар вони Всевишній раптом його можна
вилікувати Тобто навіть тут не можна
казати що вони всього зомбовані Там
тоді я намагався разомбувати їх Ось і
факту, що мені дзвонили Після цього так
сказати люди яких я знаю деякі
вони зомбувалися але вони почали дзвонити
почали а що а почали питати А що
справді так ви сполку
в Росії
тому що я не боюся їх як би навіть
зараз небезпечно зробити насправді я
кажу знаєте ми знаходимося тут у нас
є небезпека для життя Та ну всіх хто
Знаходиться в Україні навіть у безпечному
місцях теж ракета може прилетіти будь-яке
місце
тобто немає безпеки
ми не раби
каже те, що ми хочемо і тим даю
інтерв'ю хочу скажу так хочу сказати
правду кажу Так мені ніхто не змушує
а там уже там треба говорити тільки в
бік як політики партії та тобто з
одного боку я закликав євреїв покинути
Росію тому що на мій погляд і не
тільки нам і опускається залізна завіса
і потім коли захочуть покинути буде вже
пізно
ось дійсно багато хто вже покинув Ну
ось в Ізраїлі 20.000 із Росії
репатріації вже зробили за останнє
час з іншого боку є люди які
розуміють що відбувається бояться сказати
є які не розуміють
як завжди так у будь-якому місці зустрічалася
інформація про те, що в липні що не
помолюсь через суди намагалася
обрана ковдра організація до
займається репатріацією євреївців
здається і такі довелося зубами ти
фізичну діяльність тільки онлайн
там він це допомагає людям із 20 тисяч
єврей виїхала Ека за раз там ситуація
для євреїв
різні різні
думки більшість звичайно з них все
чудово розуміють що відбувається
воліє мовчати або поїхав як це
зробити
вони поїхали історія із закритим зігнутим
це перша ластівка Чому вони вдарили
сохнуть Це я вважаю що це як би
знакова справа тому що як би особливо
особливо як би не Ну добре закриється
особливо це не буде такого трагедія
це удар по організації знамениті
організації яка як би
напівдержавна організація
організація яка багато років існує
які у Радянському Союзі було заборонено
Я думаю удар підсохнуть це був такий
показник ось дивіться
перша ластівка будете поводитися добре
Та не то Вам буде погано Ви самі
нарубалася в Росії
хороший росіян Я народився в Петербурзі
місця Петербург називався
ви на росіян
я
я вважаю, що я на єрусалимець
а найкраще росіяни
Звісно є
Я ж не расист в Україні
що добрих росіян і знову розповіли
буквально днями людина яка
залишив нещодавно
знаєте що багато росіян усі розуміють
вони проти війни особливо там у розвинених
містах Москві Петербурзі багато
значно більше
я думаю що скоро може бути критична
маса
[музика]
багато є добрих росіян які можуть
зробити
громадянську позицію
Мені наступного дня після звільнення
українські війська Більш того я знав
що там відбувається припускав
ґвалтували
грабували але можна дізнатися все ж таки це
правда вбивали жорстоко катували Тобто
це все так сказати просто Вони поводилися
як
Ну як Ну а як нацисти чи як тільки
різниця була що нацисти там йшли війська
з почали Вермахт війська Так вони вони
До речі вони воювали А після СС які
які живуть вбивали там жорстоко
звірювали і так далі Це каральний
війська ось а тут теж саме функцію
робили вони ж воювали Вони ж
Каратель наскільки я знаю окремо
каральне питання їм сказали там графті
там де ось ці пральні машини йде
ганебність була і Ну що таке фашизм
Що таке
фашизм у тому сенсі як ми це
знаємо що вони зробили
найстрашніше вони зробили вони
приватизували перемогу над нацизмом
антифашисти та інших які
був Другий фронт американці
танці та інші люди Французька
опір є багато людей хто
воювала проти фашизму продемонацизму Так
вони так би мовити вони провідники ми
антифашисти типу вони кажуть інші
фашисти носять Вони вже не лише українці
вони кажуть фашисти Вони ж там
американці європейці тобто російської
людину запитав А ось ці все ось
американці це теж фашист, тобто
щось фашист ось я хочу зрозуміти я довго
над цим думав коли вони кажуть фашизм
Ми ж виховували, що фашист - це не
людина їли Так значить коли говориш на
людину його говорять ось це фашист
значить він знеособлений вже його можна
розшматувати
без слюди та слідства там не знаю
задавити танком проїхати стерти його
спалити Тобто це або раз фашист означає
можна зробити Чому вони так я так
розумію Ну може я помиляюся Але
ось це все фашисти Робіть з ними все
що завгодно все це означає ви в очах
вони не люди, інакше вони можуть фашисти
робити
Ми бачимо, що це таке так вони і в них
це кажу забуваю що він про те
що у нас президент єврей Володимир
Зеленський це мат перший знаєте
Це тому вони ж не можуть із цим
зрозуміти це ось Лавров коли сказав почав
що вони почали щоб живіт Гітлер
Гітлера теж єврейська кров, що вони
почали вони думають Як це я не знаю
як це як з цим працювати начебто
фашисти начебто президент чи як
машина фашисти могли євреї президентом
вибрати та тобто у людей у ​​голові навіть
важко це свій зводиться А ось вони пішли
вже почали говорити, а правда лавровий
там відразу на нього всі всі накинули зі
всієї єврейські організації
Зеленського
Володимира Олександрович
[музика]
На жаль Може бути скажу або до
жаль Але я є звичайно що
порадити було б але але я тільки
Благословляю багато президентів різних
країн вони хочуть приїхати
сфотографуватися Зеленський так
Невелика честь небагато людей запитують
як і бізнесмени всякі діти А як можна
зустрітися із Зеленським фотографію
тільки зробити розумієте та тобто
Зеленський став сьогоднішній день став
легендою
щоб
нічого війна це не час критикувати
мене тільки є деякі речі коли
мені під час тобто те що
коли мені сказали що Там крадуть
гуманітарну допомогу як це можна у
час війни такий
страшні речі ти треба просто випалювати
розжареним залозам
вибачаєшся такий навіть різкі такі
заяви або
під час війни Зараз саме час
виправити весь цей час говорю
всі проблеми, які були в Україні
ось корупція
хабарництво несправедливі суди Ось
це зараз треба виправляти не після
війни Що Україна сьогодні з'явилася
історичний шанс Всевишній дав побудує
державу там не знаю
саму процвітаючу у світі Так І ось не
використовувати це просто буде
не те що шкода злочин
використовувати це буде сьогодні ми
повернулася з Ізраїлю
зустрічалася з важливими людьми з
президентом Ізраїлю
ми станемо і місяцям це поспішають кувейним
і бачила Великого епіт ринку від Ізраїлю
він [ __ ] шили поставок зброєні бачили
санкції вас дикображен не залишилася шанс
що зміниться Ізраїль
веде війну за виживання вже багато років
48 роки
Україна перебуває в кращому стані
кращому положенні ніж в Ізраїль чому ж
Ізраїль колись на нього накинулися відразу
кілька арабських держав коли
тільки заснували держави в Ізраїлю не
було ні зброї не весь світ відвернувся від
його ніхто не давав зброю ніхто не
потребу зараз Україні слава Богу весь
мир за Україну та зброю може менше
звичайно хотілося набагато більше і
фінансові Так допоможу і гуманітарне так
допоможуть Україна допомагає
є такі країни, які знищити це
Іран відкрито заявляє про знищення
Ізраїлю бажання знищити
хоманський з балу тобто там ісламський
джигат і ще багато-багато-ворогів
які сплять і бачить Тільки ізраїльські
море
тому Ізраїль насамперед він
повинен думати про своє виживання і через
того що Росія Вона на кордоні з
ізраїлем теж знаходиться на півночі.
Сирії тому Ізраїлю доводиться
зважати на це я тому не можу
сказати Ізраїлю, що я можу
поясню їм що так я розумію вас але
Ось давайте давати те що можемо
Давайте оборонна річ зброя
давати не наступай на бронеті ось як
залізний купол як
те, що захищає цивільне цивільне Так
що я намагаюся зробити я зустрічаюся з
політиками зустрічався з різними
політиками намагаюся їм
поміняти їм погляд пояснюю їм Що
відбувається насправді насправді
тут не зовсім так треба по-перше
Україна багато зроблено показала що
Російська армія така як її лякали
і Ізраїль має бути має бути разом
із західним світом приїзд сюди
депутата парламенту світ баркату
ізраїльського
[музика]
і він дуже просто депутат це один з
впливових людей в Ізраїлі він перший у
на початку партії кудись яка
через півтора місяці вибору і швидше
всього мені здається, що вони знову-таки
переможуть як це було раніше і я стану
правлячої партії Ізраїль Може допомагати
Україні про це озвучував якраз на
наступного дня світ, що приїхав сюди
баркад він озвучив жорстку позицію його
позиція однозначна, що Ізраїль повинен
стати на бік України і він заявив це
в ізраїльських засобах масової
інформації зараз він полетів і він сказав
що він зараз ви побачите мої
практичні дії ви зараз ворожили
що Ізраїль у воді війну на виживання
ми Україна на виживання
по суті ви думаєте, що Україна заросла так
часто кажеш, що Україна буде така
як Ізраїль у мої будні мій спосіб вже
тя потім я до людей приймаюся по
водити
поради він каже він вважає що потрібно
для мене це було нововведення що я читав
навпаки, що тут місто відкрито Київ
відкрили так все діє Не відчувається
війна Ну як це люди повинні відчувати
він читає Ні він каже я був мером все
час був вважав, що теракт стався
відразу швидко прибрати все і відразу
Нормальне життя якнайшвидше
повернутися до нормального життя тому що
показати ворогам, що вони не зламають нас
тобто ви продовжуєте ось цієї ось
тут теж говорив І ось він радив
що потрібно якнайшвидше повертатися
у нормальному житті тому до речі його
думка зі мною розійшлися наприклад коли
він був в розумі не сказав потрібно я радив
всім не приїжджати до пуття не це саме ну
як їй теж і Україна радить Ізраїль
він сказав мені це робити. Це треба просто
зробити Як правильно навпаки
максимально не закривати те, що було
завжди
а єврейські Новий рік ви б раділи
незиготи про Ізраїль виступав зараз мені
дзвонили всі ці всі радіо телебачення Я
сказав Моя думка що постарайтеся не
приїжджати Я сказав Чому
перших Україні немає можливості зараз
забезпечити безпеку Солдати поліції
вони всі на фронті тобто інші
пріоритет по-друге Росія може зробити
різні провокації щоб звинуватити
українців як вони зазвичай роблять
це так це не ґрунтується ні на чому Але це
моя як би почуття що я на себе таку
відповідальність брати не можу
зараз два дні ось ці дні у нас уже так
сказати було дивовижне диво перейшли
на контрачеплення так українці так вони
потужно пішли що їх не зупинити що це
саме що ось по-моєму ось
тому з Божою допомогою Я думаю що
буде чудова
чудова перемога буде
це перемога це саме перемога це не
Перемир'я
а перемога
повна
взагалі побожіння українцям як падати
духом не підійду це означає бути в
Радуйся весь час коли виступаю
говорю треба бути в радість в радості в
радості коли людина сумна вона
сумнівається, що все від Бога Україна
пройшла
перший етап важкий
Україна Дякую Росії вона зробила
велику справу нас платила Україна
український народ та Всі народи навколо
України згуртувалися якщо позбавитися від
цієї спадщини радянського минулого
включаючи так би мовити
корупцію та продажні суди те що я
говорив і багато іншого і тоді можна
буде тут процвітаюча країна з
Європи сюди приїжджатимуть так би мовити
Україна це буде честь приїхати сюди
зараз уже бачите
прем'єр-міністри країн приїжджають сюди
приїхати в Україну зустрітися Зеленським
там
Україна стала топ-топ-топ
у черзі країни щоб інвестувати у
Україну розумієте
за наткнення слова і за всю розмелювання я до
вам
[музика]
Україна Ми з тобою
сини неба жовтий кулі Розкажіть по
порошо під лагідною ЗМІ текст придумає
музику
вже композитором багато
відомої пісні написав Його звуть Роман
булгачов
У нас є в Анапі в студія ми справжні
телено студія і ми там записуємо пісні
цю пісню записали Хоча спочатку не
думав що я зможу заспівати Це не мій стиль
До речі ця пісня була теж на день
Незалежності було на Центральній площі
тель-авів було десь там близько шести
тисяч людей зібралося вона була на
великому екрані моя пісня презентували
там
це відео що але мене вже До речі я можу
сказати є пісня вже майже готові
Я просто ще не заспівав але я зараз уже
є музика слова
як гімн взагалі тобто вона так би мовити
Вона Я думаю що вона тільки перемахи
якраз буде
Я йому говорю давайте приїжджайте давайте
швидше заспіваємо що перемогла вона вже не за
горами треба вже швидше встигнути пісню
записати цю ніч ми зараз ось на цій
тижнем будемо я її записувати
коротше випиває українську так я
розбавляю мені
у вашу розбавляє українська після
російської
[музика]
Браво